... and roll to victory...
with expert advice from Neil Pickup.
Has someone just challenged you
to an arm wrestle?
Well, lucky for you,
or perhaps for your opponent,
arm-wrestling isn't just about
brute strength.
Using the right technique
will not only help you to win
but will also help you
avoid any injuries.
The most effective
arm-wrestling technique
and the best way
to quickly win, is...
In the 3rd Century BC, the Greek
mathematician Archimedes
famously stated
"Give me a lever long enough and
a fulcrum on which to place it,
and I shall move the world."
"What's that got to do with arm
wrestling?" I hear you ask.
Well, actually, everything.
Your forearm is the lever and you
want to make it as long as possible.
And your elbow is the fulcrum
or pivot point
which you need to be strong.
So stand as close to the table
as you can
and tuck your elbow into your body.
Allowing the muscles in your back,
shoulder and arm to provide support.
When you grip your opponent's hand,
face your knuckles
directly to the ceiling,
creating the highest possible
position for your hand to be in.
As soon as the contest starts,
lean your body back and pull your
hand straight towards your nose.
This technique will break open
your challengers hand.
As soon as their grip begins to slip,
pull your arm diagonally
towards your other shoulder,
dropping your knees and dipping
your waist at the same time.
You've just neutralised
your rivals forearm.
Continue rolling your body down
until you inevitably taste victory.
The brilliance of the top roll,
apart from the sense of superiority
you now feel,
is that you have not
had to use any joints
but made most effective use
of your muscle power.
So even if your adversary fights
back, you will not hurt your arm.
But don’t get overconfident.
The top roll is good...
but not that good.
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)